an update but not really about the Elder
Scrolls 6 - new III showcases announced
and are we getting a mafia to remaster
I'm Lucy and welcome to your safe state
for Monday May eleventh the 10th
anniversary of skate 3 where is that
fourth one seriously
first up don't expect to hear about the
Elder Scrolls 6 anytime soon back at e3
2018 Bethesda announced that work had
started on the follow-up to the
incredibly successful Skyrim and also
been quiet on the Tamriel front since
then but there's dispute Hines took to
Twitter to answer fans who are clamoring
for more information on the game he
tweeted it's after starfield which you
pretty much know nothing about so if
you're coming at me for details now and
not years from now I'm failing to
properly manage your expectations
given that Bethesda has canceled their
e3 press conference and isn't replacing
it with a digital event who knows when
we'll even hear about starfield well
while we wait I'll get back to playing
Skyrim on my Alexa time now for not one
but two e3 showcase digital
announcements
first up Ubisoft has announced Ubisoft
forward for July 12th at 12 p.m. Pt
that's 3 p.m. ET the Twitter teaser
promises a fully digital showcase with
exclusive game news reveals and more
it's a no brainer that will likely see
more from Assassin's Creed Valhalla and
watchdogs Legion but what else could
they have up their sleeves fingers
crossed for some Splinter Cell but
that's not the only digital showcase
that's been announced the gorilla
collective is a new partnership between
loads of game publishers and developers
that'll launch a three day gaming
celebration from June 6th through to the
8th companies involved include Larry and
Paradox Interactive Zam humble and
rebellion it'll be a mix of gaming news
and announcements with the 8th being
dedicated to developer interviews and
gameplay demonstrations we're going to
be teaming up with the gorilla
collective as part of game sports play
for all this summer we're going to be
streaming all the press conferences and
bringing you all the latest gaming news
and gameplay on top of that we'll also
be streaming for Kovach relief are we
getting a mafia remaster after
posted anything for nearly two years the
official mafia Twitter account tweeted
out a single word on May 10th family
either whoever is running the account is
a big fast and furious Han oh it means
those previous reports of a remastered
game might be true in early April the
game rating and administration committee
of Korea apparently leaked mafia 2
definitive edition which take-two has
still not announced the original mafia 2
game released in 2010 for 360 ps3 and pc
therefore making 2020 its 10th
anniversary which would be a very
appropriate time for a remaster or a
remake if you ask me are you excited for
a mafia to remaster or is there
something else you prefer from the 2k
back catalog that's it for today for all
the latest gaming news make sure you
keep it GameSpot
[Music]